I think you should never be scared
[Music]
even if China is stronger
China will give you only good
here not like China and dictatorship a
fascist dictation this is my book uh
this is called
in Chinese
English American economy
we failed to appreciate history we
failed to think
and it's cost us fiercely in that today
the United States is in deep decline
the problem with GM is not
caused by Toyota
the power of the General Motors is being
caused by what General Motors and the
UAW we're not very competitive we've
been spending too much money on making
ultimately worthless stuff
you are making weapons you are making
tanks to kill people okay China is
actually making cups kittens uh clothes
we gave a lot of people you know a lot
of labs and factories and things good
jobs to make plutonium weapons uranium
weapons things of this sort for all of
these years and he didn't contribute one
eye outer to either consumption or
investment in America it was technical
waste and we're now paying the cost for
it foreign
has been revealed for some time as being
ideological as ideological as Marxism
leninism ever thought it made we take a
book and say it's in here and this is
the revealed proof whether it works or
not
[Music]
foreign
China is a very promising country I'm
sure in 20 years we'll catch up with USA
foreign
[Music]
the world hegemon has historically
always been the world's most powerful
economic Nation the United States hasn't
been the most powerful economic Nation
for a long time now
and it doesn't look like it's going to
come back
the decline of the United States as the
world hegemon is a necessary condition
in order for China to take over that
role
hey what's up
but there's hegemon necessarily mean
Empire
the hegemon simply refers to an
overarching power by Empire then I think
it's a little bit like pornography you
know when you see it
as China unleashes its tremendous
talents as well as the power of its size
and productivity it certainly is
assuming
a hegemonic position but I don't think
China quite qualifies as an Empire right
now but historically when countries have
become hegemens they eventually become
Empires
Rome
Britain
[Music]
Germany
[Applause]
Japan
[Music]
foreign
Russia
and let's not forget the United States
[Music]
the Americans don't realize we have
probably a good thousand overseas
military bases
China doesn't yet have this military
capability
but what happens when it becomes the
world's number one economy
will hegemony lead it to become the
world's next Empire
or does it provide a much needed balance
to American militarism
[Music]
should we be afraid
seeing as believing so come to China and
have a look seeing is believing so let's
go
but not only to China let's go to the
countries that surround China and see
how they're being treated
is China being a friendly neighbor
or is it sowing the seeds
of Empire
[Music]
China already uses its neighbors to play
Big Country politics
Busan South Korea
one of the world's major shipping ports
and evidence of the successful
industrialization of South Korea whose
living standards now rival those of the
United States
the U.S considers South Korea a key Ally
in East Asia
and it hopes that China will help to
resolve the growing nuclear threat posed
by neighboring North Korea
like much U.S policy it misunderstands
Chinese interests
[Music]
Korea used to be a tributary or
satellite state of the historical
Chinese Empire
at one point even referring to itself as
a sojunghwa or Little China
it was split in two during the 1950 to
1953 Korean Civil War
[Music]
with the reclusive communist North
allying itself with Russia and China
meanwhile the self chose developmental
capitalism and relied heavily on the
vast consumer markets of the United
States to propel its rapid
industrialization through export-driven
growth
soul
the nation's capital has a little more
than a quarter of the country's
population of 48 million
it sits precariously at 50 kilometers
from the demilitarized zone separating
the two sides in range of the North's
artillery
threat of souls all-out destruction in
the event of further conflict has helped
maintain this status quo for five
decades
just how serious a threat is North
Korea's development of nuclear weapons
[Music]
thank you
in order for a country to become a
full-fledged nuclear weapons State the
country should satisfy four conditions
the first condition is the possession of
nuclear warhead
yes North Korea has acquired nuclear
warhead second it should have delivery
capability
North Korea has a delivery capability it
has intermediate range ballasting
missile not on one and Northern two it
has a short range missiles such as skirt
B and C
third nuclear testing but there is a
debate on whether it was successful or
not and finally in order to mount that
wirehead on the short and medium range
missiles no Square should for just
miniaturation technology but we believe
that the northgrade is short of
acquiring the miniaturation technology
in view of that we can argue that North
Korea is a very dangerous country with a
potential nuclear weapons capability but
we cannot regard North Korea ads to
factor for a full-fledged nuclear weapon
state I don't find the Korean situation
unstable I've never felt that there was
a threat from North Korea I've never
thought for a minute there was a single
North Korean that was even slightly
suicidal
suicidal or not a nuclear North shifts
the balance of power in Asia
why doesn't China use its growing
strength to help U.S backed efforts to
disarm North Korea
what are the odd things about the
post-war world is the Chinese are
absolutely delighted to have Korea
divided into they used to try and
maintain this even back in the Tang
Dynasty Korea was often structurally
divided into different kingdoms with
different supports from the Chinese
because it led to structural weakness
inability to stand up to a Chinese
domination
their policy is to prevent war and
prevent the unification of Korea
um
initially you know when you know let's
say we go back to the January and
February 2003 what the Bush
Administration wanted was no
press China in such a way the chinaood
pose
sanctions in North Korea China didn't
want it if you're going to work on a
Korean nuclear issues you have to
understand the Chinese context and the
fact that South Korea is rich is fine
but if Korea we're unified and this Rich
it would be the size of former West
Germany that's getting to be a little
too big for Chinese comfort
if Korea is a traditional tributary
state that China manages through
division
then how will it deal with Korea is
bigger and wealthier neighbor Japan
whose rivalries with China
have spanned centuries
the answer depends not only on the
intentions of the Chinese government
but also on the attitudes of the Chinese
people
like Korea Japan has traditionally been
a part of the Chinese cultural area
but it has also been fiercely rebellious
After Japan became the first Asian
Nation to industrialize it used its
Newfound strength to create a modern
Empire and subjugate its Asian Neighbors
foreign
heinous war crimes and killing
approximately 30 million Chinese
throughout Asia
understandably there exists a strong
current of anti-japanese sentiment among
many Chinese today
although Japan was defeated in World War
II it went on to become the world's
second largest economy
China however is now on the verge of
surpassing its old rival
to many both inside China and out the
2008 Beijing Olympics were a symbol of
China's rebirth as Asia's preeminent
power
part of the Beijing Olympic torch relay
the Chinese decided to bring the torch
to Nagano Japan home of the 1998
Japanese Olympics
perhaps as a message to the world that
the Middle Kingdom was about to eclipse
the Land of the Rising Sun
[Music]
this message came a tremendous display
of nationalism
in the form of thousands of young
Chinese
[Music]
many received encouragement and even
financial support for their travels to
Nagano from various Chinese consulates
throughout Japan
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
the Chinese government requested that
the relay began at zenkology Temple the
same starting point as that of Japan's
1998 Olympics
actually the Olympic Games is a very
good opportunity for China most of the
students in China View it as a great
opportunity for us to to present
ourselves
however days before the torch run the
temple announced concerns about the
treatment of fellow Buddhists in Tibet
at the hands of the Chinese and refused
to host the Chinese torch
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
the event attracted a large number of
loosely associated protesters who took
the torch relay as an opportunity to
voice grievances against China
foreign
[Applause]
we don't like the protesters
because they try to insert political
implications to this non-political event
what do you think about the new railroad
that goes to Wausau
um
good however most important is how to
use
so
that should be used for Tibet people
yeah
[Applause]
hey
you know they're they're supporting you
maybe
[Applause]
[Music]
they don't know who is right
I understand that the protesters they
need to get attention of the world but I
don't think Olympics is a good timing
because Olympic is is a proud of
everyone of of Chinese people so if you
protest it you are opposing the Chinese
people
[Applause]
[Music]
Beyond being a window on Chinese
nationalism the Nagano torch relay
provided a glimpse into the situation of
some of China's various ethnic
minorities
and beg the question is China really the
unified multi-ethnic nation that it
portrays
[Music]
thank you
in China's idea from Asian to until now
we stress harmonious
harmonious you know Confucius
Confucius
yeah from his period two thousand years
ago he teach us be friendly
no matter where you come from all corner
of the world
we have one family
we are friends
the Olympics provided an opportunity to
see if the harmonious Society was a
reality or simply propaganda
we headed to xinjiang meaning new
territory to watch the Olympic torch
relay in kashgar
yeah
inside kashgar City preparations for the
torch relay were underway
in a show of ethnic solidarity for the
Olympics the authorities were preparing
a large group of minority children
mostly uyghurs to come out and show
support for the torch on the day of the
Run
[Music]
the event itself however was sealed off
from the public
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we were struck by just how different
xinjiang was from Eastern China and we
wanted to know more
specifically just who were the uyghurs
well to begin with they're Central
Asians of turkic origin and they're
Muslim
[Music]
[Applause]
like other Muslim cultures the uyghurs
treat guests with the utmost hospitality
and we were invited by a man off the
street to share tea with his family
like many of the minorities we met he
asked that we obscure his face and voice
and then
foreign
can we ask him when he thinks about Iraq
War
afterwards we spoke to another uyghur
farmer and his family
[Applause]
foreign
Factory
a lot of little bed for the farming yeah
cement cement factories are
we knew we hadn't gotten the whole story
but our guide wouldn't give us any more
details on what had been said
although uyghurs are by far the largest
ethnic group in xinjiang there are a
number of smaller ones
we spoke to a uyghur-speaking ethnic
tajik at his home
he's happy about the communistic party
of China yeah
[Music]
they made fire and over in the house all
of the inside of the house is smoke
actually you are very bad environment
but now nothing because he has a new
house yes
but so what is the relationship to the
Communist Party
uh
they are very very satisfied with the
party
yeah he said never be able to find
another party like this
it wasn't until we caught up with exiled
uyghur spokeswoman Rabia khadir at the
uyghur American Association in
Washington DC that we felt like we got
the other side of the story
um
foreign
here
go to Tajikistan
they don't
have the permission to go to Tajikistan
because Tajikistan is another country
this is the small company
so
they have no permission to go abroad
some relatives of him in Tajikistan they
will be able to visit him okay but he
doesn't again
foreign
Ty should be a society that balance the
interest of different groups of people
for example the wealthy and the poor uh
the majority and minority people the
urban and rural residents and also it
should be balanced between people and
the environment
we asked the uyghur American Association
to provide a re-translation of the
kashgar cement factory clip and this old
weaker farmer is complaining about the
cement factory right across his farmland
because as a manufactory which is new
rebuilt it's modernized and it's
polluting the air the water especially
the Farmland as Farmers they could no
longer grow anything
he used to grow some melons and some
other fruits
in the Farmland here but now he could
not grow anything and he's really not
happy about it and he can do absolutely
nothing about it and he's complaining
basically if the Chinese were living in
this neighborhood than the city
government and the Environmental
Protection Agency would have taken some
measures to prevent the pollution but
now the factory and the city government
are doing absolutely nothing because he
says
the local government officials were
corrupt and they were probably bought by
the cement factory so they can do
absolutely nothing about it
and uh
it's really sad for them as farmers
yeah
um
[Music]
foreign
but couldn't the uyghurs reach out for
help from their close Muslim neighbors
the pakistanis
um
foreign
wait a minute Pakistan gets favors from
China
we were confused
[Music]
we thought Pakistan was supposed to be a
key U.S Ally
not China's
[Music]
it's also a predominantly Muslim country
so at the very least wouldn't its people
sympathize with the situation of the
uyghurs in China
[Music]
just what type of a relationship does
China have with Pakistan
[Music]
we decided a visit to Pakistan was in
order
[Music]
there are two Nations which are fighting
in the world one is America one is China
so America is using brutal way which is
war and there is a lot of losses and
China is using a peaceful way and
civilized way where there is no loss
[Music]
[Applause]
they don't interfere okay and other
countries it is not like America it is
not like America who interfere in the
entire world
[Applause]
[Music]
get your feelings
the United States is one of the largest
donors of foreign aid to Pakistan
but most of this money is spent on
American-made arms and weapon systems
the Pakistani military justifies such
spending as being necessary to defend
against the imagined threat of its Arch
Enemy India
American Aid therefore does little to
help actual pakistanis
fortunately for the pakistanis there are
other nations that have undertaken
development projects that have
contributed greatly to the
infrastructure and quality of life in
Pakistan China has been our friend for
the last 50 years if Pakistan had any
problem in the past China came and it
solved the problem of Pakistan
the karakorum highway is the highest
International roadway in the world
it runs over 800 miles from kashgar in
western China to Islamabad Pakistan
the kkh is a joint venture between China
and Pakistan that provides a vital link
between the two countries
a quiet graveyard just off the highway
commemorates the 82 Chinese workers who
lost their lives in Pakistan during the
20 years it took to complete the
construction of the kkh
the karakorum highway would not exist
today were it not for the funding hard
work and sacrifice of the Chinese
before the construction of kkh
the people of northern areas led a very
poor life after construction of kkh we
experienced different sort of changes
culturally
economically
socially and politically even
our northern areas there is a new
industry only jobs litter jobs and small
homemade things a China is the only one
of the country who provide the
wheelchair stuff for our people
we are six hours drive from our border
to China so easily we are going to
China is so near for us so we want to
business with China
in addition to inexpensive consumer
goods Chinese technology is also brought
to Pakistan through the karakoram the
Chinese technology is very cheap
so the local authorities and Pakistani
government accept their bids
and they allowed them to establish their
projects
there is an agreement between Chinese
government and Pakistani government
for widening the cake age for lying the
railway line
as well as gas pipeline
so the local in population is very happy
they will benefit it
the Chinese have also begun other Mega
projects in Pakistan
such as investing 200 million dollars in
the construction of gwadar port on the
southern coast of the country
guadar is considered by the Chinese as
as their Avenue to a warm water port
report which is strategically close to
where oil supplies go through a port
which gives them access to the Indian
Ocean and the Arabian Sea a port that
they can use as a trade Corridor so
there's a whole idea of linking water
through uh Balochistan onwards up
through Northern Pakistan through the
karakoram highway going on through
xinjiang and onwards into Central Asia
While most of these plans have yet to
become reality they reflect the ongoing
and serious interest of the Chinese in
maintaining close ties with Pakistan
one region of Pakistan that remains in
great need of Developmental Aid is the
Northwest Frontier Province and the
federally administrated tribal areas
bordering Afghanistan
[Music]
this region is Infamous as a center of
the Pakistani Taliban
foreign oh the american-backed effort to
expel the Soviets from Afghanistan in
the 1980s provided weapons and training
to the Afghan mujahideen
but the needs of the impoverished Afghan
refugees who fled to neighboring
Pakistan went unnoticed in Washington
they worked for eight hours a day
do you go to school
he doesn't go to school
they say that they don't have money to
afford going to school like their father
of Espada is very poor
now all these guys look they should go
to school but they are working with
their parents and now it's almost one
o'clock in the afternoon time and the
temperature is over 40 degrees and they
are working for their family because
that to buy food or buy clothes or other
requirements of life
those who cannot afford to attend public
schools find that their only opportunity
for an education lies in the Islamic
madrasas a little bit of business the
madrasas provide a free education and
books room and board to the students
[Music]
students Begin by memorizing the Quran
once they have done this they study
other subjects like history logic
philosophy and the hadiths or sayings
and deeds of the Prophet Muhammad
doesn't doesn't help us the government
doesn't support us the government
doesn't fund us and the government
provide us front then we will start
engineering subjects or science science
medical subjects or other subjects or
computer subjects
if I'm helpless so I have to take the
hand of someone okay so that he can help
me and fight for me and if you have one
side China and one side America civil uh
we will be in the favor of China we'll
support China we will work for China
[Music]
foreign
glasses of wine and they said to each
other
they hoped very soon they will send the
American naked ass from Afghanistan
China's reputation as a friendly
neighbor does not stop at Pakistan's
border
[Music]
it has successfully been out competing
the U.S for the favor of Afghanistan
itself
[Music]
foreign
ly 30 years of war abandoned artillery
litter the landscape of Afghanistan like
tombstones marking the graveyard of
Empires
the end of experience with the war we
fought the Soviets at the end that
superpower was broken
[Music]
billions being spent on so-called Aid in
development the country has become
increasingly dependent on opium
production with many blaming corruption
and even NATO forces for the country's
inability to move forward America wants
to solve everything by the gun gun is
not does not bring Solutions God
increases the problems
like in Pakistan the Chinese have
stepped in to fill the developmental
void left by the United States right now
in this reconstruction period in
Afghanistan Chinese they are holding
some construction company they have
built they are busy in some road
construction they are not even telling
our government who should be a minister
who would be a governor all they are
saying that they want to see or develop
and prosperous Afghanistan
however like its Western peers China's
interest in Afghanistan is not purely
humanitarian
rich and mineral resources Afghanistan
remains an undeveloped source of raw
materials in the world in which they are
increasingly scarce
it is Afghanistan's copper that
interests China
[Music]
the medal is used in all aspects of
modern life including coinage jewelry
housing Transportation electronics and
Medicine
[Music]
Afghanistan's untapped inacc copper
deposit in Logan province is said to be
one of the world's largest
valued at almost 90 billion dollars
is
the China metallurgical group has bought
a 30-year lease for three billion
dollars
the largest foreign investment in
Afghanistan's history
the royalties alone will cover almost
half of the Afghan government's annual
budget
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
on July 7th 2008 the Indian Embassy in
Kabul fell victim to a suicide bomber
many including the government of the
United States believe the attack was
carried out in concert with the isi or
Pakistani intelligence Service as an act
of Terror against India
[Music]
when I come out from the shop I see a
lot of people was running outside the
shop a person was injured in his head he
was he was full of blood a lot of people
was running in front of the hospital so
the ambulances come the police's
security is surrounded by the embassy
and they was not allowing any people
foreign
most of the Wounded were treated at the
nearby jamuriat hospital
built by China as a gift to the Afghan
people
fortunately for Pakistan
the U.S decided to look the other way
an American help was nowhere to be seen
good
will China show the same level of tacit
approval
or will it chide its Pakistani friends
for sponsoring an unprovoked attack
against Afghanistan and India
[Music]
India
home of 1.2 billion people
in 20 years it will have a bigger
population than China
its economy continues to grow year after
year
and it's the world's largest democracy
could India provide a cultural and
strategic counterbalance to China
one of the main balancing forces in the
emerging world of Asia South and East
Asia is going to be India and China that
neither is going to feel comfortable
with one achieving a position of
superiority least of all any claims to
hegemony I would assume Asia is a target
for the Chinese
they would like to put Asia under under
its control in economic terms in
political terms in strategic and
military terms ah this is where China
has been active India is very conscious
of China and Rise of China
and also very much conscious of the
difficulties that India has had with
Pakistan it is interesting to see that
China and Pakistan have shared a very
important relationship over last four
decades
and in some ways there is a suspicion
attached in much of Indian mind as to
what is the modus operandi what are the
motivations compulsions of such a strong
and close relationship and often
insinuation that it is perhaps
anti-india
[Music]
they're friendly to Pakistan
beijing's influence also reaches into
delhi's internal politics
[Music]
masala
the home of the Tibetan government in
Exile
[Music]
after the Chinese took control of Tibet
in 1959 the Dalai Lama and his
government fled in 1959 when Chinese
invaded Tibet we have very poor military
if we had a very strong military in
Japan during that time I think that
Tibet wouldn't have been occupied
although the U.S and the U.N were
actively trying to prevent the spread of
Communism they did not help the Tibetans
India did
and then enraged China made them pay a
bloody price culminating in the 1962
sino-indian War
after Dalai Lama walked into India the
overall China India relations
deteriorated completely
the Chinese claim that they are bringing
Economic Development and modernization
to Tibet and its feudal society and
Simon criticizes us because China says
that you know Tibet was a feudal country
feudal society there was no
people were exploited
and of course everyone you know for us
you know we we agreed that Tibet was not
a perfect Society
but each year scores of Tibetans risk
disfiguring frostbite to cross the
Himalayas into India
today refugees from Tibet continue to
find new homes in dharamsala
oh
so why do so many of them come here
my name is Lisa young I'm from New
Zealand and I've been volunteering with
LA for almost two months La is sort of a
community college for adults Tibetan
refugees and Tibetans who have just
newly arrived in India who are not
eligible for the school system here
because they're too old so it's for
refugees from 18 to 40 mainly and they
teach free English and Tibetan classes
French also Computing classes and job
vocational training
and they hear about the education system
that's been set up for Tibetans in India
which is separate from the Indian school
system and that's quite often the
impetus for them to make the the Exile
trick over the Himalayas to India
um yeah that and the two main reasons
are better education and seeing the
Dalai Lama because the education in
Tibet is mainly in Mandarin and they
don't get much of a chance to speak
Tibetan and they basically have to learn
the Chinese curriculum and a lot of them
choose not to they don't want to they
want to learn about Tibet in its culture
and it's definitely a lot more preserved
here especially in darum Sala
yeah
[Music]
many Tibetans feel that their ancient
culture is being systematically erased
by the Han Chinese
[Music]
so these are the teachings
and it has 108 balloons
and these are the commentaries written
by the Indian Masters
it has 225 worms
[Music]
so some text even they carry it from
Department
it was damaged by the water you know
how many of these types of texts did the
Chinese destroy you know
uh I can't say the exit number but there
are
60 or 60 percent is destroyed by the
Chinese
so they just destroyed they just burned
and they just throw into the water
[Music]
India's ability to operate independently
from Beijing is eroding if you were to
look around Asia
China has replaced the U.S as the
largest trading partner for almost every
country in the region
India China trade has been growing
rapidly
and a trade route has even been opened
that directly connects India and China
through Tibet
indeed India China trade has crossed
India U.S trade in terms of sheer
numbers there's a growing relation trade
relation bilateral relation between
these two countries I think that gives
Chinese a certain power which people
will look over their shoulder twice
before they do or say something that
gets meijing upset Chinese have done
committed a lot of atrocities and
they've been allowed to get away with it
because they've been isolated for so
long
um there's a lot there's a period where
no one knows what went on in China and
now that they've opened up they're still
sort of acting with impunity because of
the economic incentive countries aren't
willing to speak out trade has lately
become very China driven India is always
very careful about the Tibet issue and
also with its visitors with its relation
with China I think it's a tightrope that
New Delhi has to walk between its
increasingly closer relations with the
Beijing and also keeping Tibetan
refugees population satisfied as much as
we can
yeah
in March of 2008 there were protests
across Tibet before the Chinese hosted
the Olympics
many Tibetans in India decided to show
their support by marching towards Tibet
[Music]
you know when we LED this March
you know we marched we walked for nearly
four months
[Music]
in the Indian central government
they have sent us orders saying that you
can't move out of
this District Ghana District India will
not allow
Indian Territory to be used by any
Tibetan protesters to undertake any
political activities
[Music]
at beijing's request Delhi had its own
police and forced the wishes of the
Chinese government by cracking down on
the protesters
yeah you know
um China is a very China is very clever
and it can't use any country for their
own benefit at any point of time
so when we were reaching the Drisco The
District border very early morning the
Police Stopped us so from our side
because we have a dream what we did was
we sat down on the road in the middle of
the middle of the road and we started
praying and some people were crying and
we all got locked ourselves we started
praying
and that made impossible for them to get
angry
you know
and you know they have their own
response but they have their duty to
perform they have to arrest us
[Music]
I think perhaps I feel a bit of an
affinity to the Tibetan people because
my parents went or at least my mother I
don't know about my father went through
the cultural revolution
[Music]
it's just weighing on me a little bit
because everyone thinks I'm Tibetan when
I'm here which is lovely because I've
really grown to love the Tibetan people
but before I came here I was warned by a
lot of local Indian people and also
tourists that have been here when I told
them that I was Chinese they were really
surprised
[Music]
some people were actually saying quite
extreme things like that people might
think I was a spy from China and that
people will react negatively here they
would get angry with me and they if I'm
not angry then they would be staring at
me and they'd make my stay heavily
uncomfortable
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
I had to decide whether I was going to
tell people here that I was Chinese and
unfortunately I decided not to
me
and I think that was a mistake because I
think they would have accepted me fine
like they've they've got friends in
Tibet that are Chinese and they're very
open and welcoming of Chinese people
because that's what the Dalai Lama
teaches them to show compassion to
everyone your enemies and your friends
India is not the only country where
China tries to control Tibetans outside
of its National borders
Nepal is home to 28 million people it is
sandwiched between two giants India and
China
India has always had a significant
influence on the culture of Nepal its
economics and tree
[Music]
but China has become increasingly active
in the politics of Nepal
with much Chinese attention placed on
the 20 000 Tibetan refugees who reside
there
[Music]
the t word is predominant vis-a-vis
China's relations with Nepal I think
what the defendants are doing here what
the Americans are doing here
is of utmost concern to the Chinese
these began coming to Nepal after the
Chinese occupation of Tibet the
[Music]
jawala Kell camp in Kathmandu is home to
a thousand refugees
and about 500 are employed there
manufacturing woven carpets
[Music]
Paul is wary of being seen as helping
the Tibetan refugees too much to
counterbalance our overwhelming
political and economic dependence
on India we try to lean over backwards
to be nice to China
it's pretty clear that the Tibetan
protests the Chinese don't like it
they're extremely sensitive to this and
that sensitivity is very easily brought
to bear on the Nepal government so if
the Chinese are going to be angry about
Tibetans running around in Nepal we're
willing to give that a sympathetic year
and track down on Tibetans here as long
as China is happy
the Nepali government's treatment of
Tibetan protesters is clearly different
than its treatment of Nepali protesters
police ignore burning Effigies and tires
and blocking roads as long as it's done
by nepales
[Applause]
although the treatment of Tibetan
refugees in Nepal may seem similar on
the surface to their treatment in India
the mechanism behind it is far different
for 10 years a bloody Civil War raged
across Nepal
as maoist Rebels took up arms against
the king and the maoists gained popular
support
after the King was forced out of power
in 2008 the maoists were elected to run
the new government
[Music]
the party's name is a clear tribute to
China's German Mao
um
[Applause]
during the Civil War Sherpas camping in
the remote snowy passes of the Himalaya
reported seeing Caravans of ponies
loaded with guns Crossing from China
into Nepal during the dead of night
policy the international policies is a
eco-distance relation
not more close to the India not more
close to China
India has historically been the major
influence on life in Nepal
so in practice a policy of equal
distance will require Nepal to realign
its interests more closely to China's
while the maoists claim to have brought
democracy to Nepal in reality their
behavior is consistent with that of
their namesake
[Music]
thank you
Mao is stormed the offices of the Nepali
times and physically assaulted kunda
Dixit and his staff in an attempt to
silence the Press
[Music]
China was able to benefit from the
maoist's willingness to destroy the
freedoms of expression in Nepal
in response to pressure from China Nepal
agreed to ban all anti-china activity on
its soil
[Music]
China is bringing the pole within its
orbit
[Music]
once China controls a territory
what's in store for its future
let's take a look at Hong Kong
[Music]
Hong Kong is one of the world's most
developed cities
[Music]
an icon of Asia
the pearl of the East
Hong Kong has also long been at the
center of Imperial disputes
it was taken by the British Empire from
the Qing Dynasty after the first Opium
War
s
after reunification the Chinese promised
to preserve Hong Kong's highly
successful wazifera economy and its
political autonomy rule of law and
western-style civil liberties
under a paradigm that would be dubbed
One country two systems
this is why Hong Kong is so crucial it
is a litmus test for Chinese intentions
when China gains control over an economy
or political system what happens
can China be trusted to respect that
system's autonomy
or will China try to dominate it
and unlike other parts of China perhaps
the best test is not how ethnic
minorities are treated but rather
religious minorities like the falun gong
if you went to a bumpy into one Hong
Kong is
or ask some
Hustler most sensitive test over one
country two system is following issue
the following gong is a modern Chinese
spiritual practice that was founded in
China in 1992.
spiritual
so it's deep roots in
principles are three words truthfulness
compassion tolerance and we believe
that's the principle that the entire
universe operates under
its explosive popularity scared the
Chinese Communist Party
on the 20th of July 1999 it was bad
and the brutal campaign of persecution
began in the mainland
[Music]
falun gong practitioners sought Refuge
all over the world
including Taiwan Japan the U.S and even
Hong Kong
compared to China Hong Kong remained an
island of tolerance for the falun gong
even today as busloads of tourists from
the mainland come to visit Hong Kong and
take in the view from Victoria Peak
falun gong practitioners are free under
Hong Kong's Constitution
to peacefully demonstrate in support of
their beliefs
including displays about human rights
violations by the Chinese government
on the surface it would appear that one
country two systems is working
or is it
one of the issues raised when you
introduce Hong Kong is whether or not
the the Chinese idea of one country two
systems is stable I don't think so Under
beijing's Pressure the Hong Kong
government routinely violates its own
Constitution by refusing entry to fall
on gong practitioners who try to visit
the territory every country have an
immigration control they are entitled to
refuse someone no problem but racial and
religious discrimination cannot be a
reason of refusing people's enter
so when we talk about one country two
systems it's like you know gradually
really disappearing
is one country two systems starting to
become one country one system
foreign
[Music]
from six-year-old kid to 80 something
aged
old lady
well violently repatriate
from Hong Kong to Taiwan
the useless some kind of black rapper me
like this one on here until the Panola
news
in detail we have no water no
refreshment
no place to rest
[Music]
so you can see
how hostile they are it's not like a
free Society it's not like a pearl over
Eastern
why
they call a blackhead the invisible hand
behind Hong Kong government
the Chinese regime watch
[Music]
foreign
defeated by the Chinese Communists the
kmt or Chinese nationalists led by
Chiang Kai-shek fled to the island of
Taiwan and designated Taipei as the
capital of the Republic of China in
1949.
the kmt ruled the island under an
oppressive authoritarian regime
but it was successful in creating rapid
economic growth that has made Taiwan one
of the most industrialized countries in
the world
eventually the kmt's iron grip gave way
to a democratic system in Taiwan
creating the first true ethnic Chinese
Democracy in world history
[Music]
most important thing for every for each
citizen is to be independent I mean
yourself
so you have to independent and then the
contributed so I think that's the most
important thing I'm not that kind of
nationalist independent guy but I mean I
want an independent country with all the
independent citizens think independently
and do independently and vote in it
randomly
try to think everything independently
don't believe in Media
so I think the citizen should be smarter
and should we try to control the
politicians try to use the politicians
as the tools to achieve your ideals
[Music]
an authoritarian regime and Rapid
economic growth leading to Chinese
Democracy
could Taiwan be a model for the future
of mainland China
if democracy exists in
um
and is established strengthened in this
region I believe it's not just it will
not just benefit the people in Taiwan
but also benefit surrounding countries
especially China the youngsters on the
mainland their gradually changing their
world view you know
they are not that young were looking
anymore or they can see by themselves
what's going on in in Taiwan especially
in taiwan's
Democratic developments
in the long run we can change the very
nature of the Chinese communism
and hoping that someday that many China
can be converted into a free and
Democratic Society and we believe that
China is moving to a right direction
that develops the economy and improve
the quality of life of everyone and at
the same time promote the democracy and
equity
[Music]
as the Chinese economy has grown a
process of normalization between Taiwan
and the mainland has begun
I hope that the mainland in Taiwan could
come together to work out a better
system and also be not more connected
investment trade and political exchange
have grown at a rapid Pace this is a
very critical moment for us
to develop a healthy and a better
relations with Chinese mainland
but is this ultimately good for Taiwan
or does economic integration with China
pose a threat to Taiwanese democracy
foreign
they try to create this image that um at
least symbolically that they're a
peaceful country they are rising
peacefully and they wish to to deliver
this sense of sincere to the world that
we're Rising economically and
politically but in a way that work
stability will be maintained we need to
accept that China become really a big
Power in the world but the problem is
that what kind of China we want in the
future in the 21st century
some some people are talking about that
China may replace the United States in
the future but if this China is an
authoritarian China I don't think it's
really a very good thing for the world
for the humanity being a big country
being a big strong country United United
States of America should Mount pressure
on the Chinese government if the West
really wanted to speak up it would but
it choose is not to because our products
come from China we rely on China's
economy we never ask ourselves what do
we do however if it gets really so rich
that they're Richard we are and that we
are making ourselves utterly dependent
upon the world is
as relying on China a lot at the moment
and it's it's too afraid to really speak
up for Tibet or for any of the other
issues I believe that the international
company should continue to talk about
the human rights problem the democracy
in China if not I believe you are just
helping to create a new Empire and I
believe it's not good really for the
21st century
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey
don't survive
[Music]
foreign